hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown amid civil
unrest over the death of George Floyd
and protests sweeping the nation it has
been a tumultuous week for America White
House spokesman Hogan get Lee Jones host
Lisa Brady to discuss how President
Trump is answering critics questioning
his actions during this trying time and
his plan to help reunite the nation also
the presidential election is less than
five months away Fox News Sunday anchor
Chris Wallace joins host Chris foster to
discuss the commander-in-chief's feud
with Twitter mail and voting and how
protests could affect the 2020 race Plus
commentary from former Utah congressman
and Fox News contributor jason Chaffetz
the Fox News rundown is a Daily News
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to FoxNews podcast.com
world or Avera I'm Emily Campania and
I'm Eric Sean this is a Fox News rundown
Friday June 5th 2020
and Lisa Brady love him or hate him the
president certainly has a lot on his
plate first the pandemic and its
shutdowns now civil unrest sweeping the
country while he also has to fight off
the critics you have the right president
for the right time in that no one moves
faster than he does no one is more up to
the challenge than he is I'm Chris
Foster Fox News Sunday host Chris
Wallace says things have been better
no rioting and the looting which was our
of all of me you know they're
lawbreakers they should be put in jail
and then put that in the context that
we've been going through this
coronavirus for three months and 40
million Americans are unemployed and
it's it's a facing a tough time in this
country right and I'm jason Chaffetz
I've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
as protests spurred by the death of
George Floyd continue US Attorney
General William bar telling the country
the Justice Department will do its part
our Constitution mandates equal
protection of the laws and nothing less
is acceptable the for fired officers
charged in Floyd's death in Minnesota
remain under separate Justice Department
and FBI probes for possible civil rights
violations but Barr is at the center of
a related controversy the clearing of a
park near the White House Monday just
before the president's photo-op at st.
John's Church there is no correlation
between our our tactical plan of moving
the perimeter app by one block and the
president's going over to the church it
was supposed to be cleared earlier in
the day but it's the level of force used
or at least the appearance of it that
remains a flashpoint
for some including president Trump's
former defense chief James Madison is
the first president in his lifetime to
not even pretend to try to unite the
country and accusing him of using a
militarized response to violate
constitutional rights that's a
ridiculous claim about moving protesters
out of a Lafayette Square being a
flashpoint Hogan Gidley is the deputy
assistant to the president and principal
deputy press secretary the flashpoint I
believe started days before if not the
night before in which these these people
many of whom were peaceful were staying
there protesting while others decided
that they were going to burn down a
church they were going to burn down the
bathroom facilities on Lafayette Square
they were going to hurl projectiles at
our brave men and women in law
enforcement whether they be frozen water
bottles rocks they discovered pipes and
other sharp objects hidden and stashed
throughout the city they'd received
intelligence reports that that they were
going to move on law enforcement and try
and and and hurt them and kill them so
the flashpoint came nights before and
it's almost as though the media is
telling us shame on you for not letting
these criminals come back and finish
what they started
you should have let them burn that
church to the ground on the second night
you should have let them destroy
monuments across this city and you
should have let them break into shops
and stores and crash through the windows
and steal all of the merchandise you
should have let them do that it's what
the media and many on the Left are
telling us and this president is not
going to allow that because his job the
federal government's job is to protect
the American people and we've said that
time and time again he's done that time
and time again in this instance is no
different maybe the timing is really
part of the issue here because I know
that the White House has said the
Attorney General actually ordered the
sqaure cleared earlier in the day I mean
do you think maybe if it had happened
then instead of later right before the
president walked over that the reaction
would have been any different I don't
because what you're trying to do now is
ascribe sensibility and common sense to
a group of people with a design to
destroy design to defame they've done it
the night before they prepared to do it
the next day just because they were
waiting for the cover of darkness to to
do it again doesn't make any difference
it doesn't matter what time you try to
move people out of the way if they're
throwing rocks at you if they're
throwing projectiles at you if if
they're becoming violent if they're
climbing statues if they're climbing
buildings if they're trying to set fires
that's they're a mob for a reason
because they lack that that rationality
and so the timing of it I think is a
scapegoat the fact is they were
preparing to do the same thing in
Lafayette Square that night that they
did the previous night and the president
wants our streets to be safe he wants
American families to feel a sense of
security across this country and quite
frankly as American citizens we deserve
that the president
has offered his own responses to at
Madison the Atlantic this week calling
him the world's most overrated general
but other former top military officials
are openly criticizing the president too
and how Speaker Nancy Pelosi calls the
presence of troops at the Lincoln
Memorial stunning and scary she's
raising concern about hundreds of
National Guard members from other areas
brought into DC we're in a very
difficult situation and has to be
handled with care we certainly want to
support peaceful demonstrations we all
reject violence in a tweet Thursday
night president Trump calling arsonists
looters criminals and anarchists the
problem he's also called for healing not
hatred so what's his plan how does he
try to unite the country the president's
also called for healing not hatred what
is his plan for that how is he trying to
unite the country well he's given
several speeches on the subject
demonstrating an understanding of the
grave injustice to George Floyd you'll
remember at the SpaceX launch the
president's eloquent words pointed out
the fact that not only was he appalled
and sickened by the video of the police
officer senselessly and needlessly
kneeling on a man's neck to the point of
death but he also called the Family
expressed his sincere condolences told
them that justice must be done in the
case we will stand with the family of
George Floyd with the peaceful
protesters and with every law-abiding
citizen who wants decency civility
safety and security you know the
president is is is responsible for
protecting the American people which he
is doing he's also one who wants to
ensure that the tensions deescalate that
the temperatures come down across the
country he's tried to do that not just
with law and order but with you know a
sense of understanding of where we are
as a nation let's not forget it was
president who sent the FBI and the DOJ
and to expedite this case because he
wants to see justice done he wants to
see it done quickly this president has
stood up for all people across this
country regardless of race religion
color or creed he's done it before he'll
do it again he does say he's done more
for the african-american community than
any president since Abraham Lincoln I
mean we've heard him talk many times
about historically low unemployment
rates before the pandemic hit of course
how else does he make that case one of
the things he did was codified funding
for historically black colleges and
universities into law no previous
president had done that he gave them
more money than any president in history
but it's not just about giving people
money or ensuring education he also
developed Opportunity Zones
in hundreds of communities cities across
this country where you'd have a
public-private partnership and industry
would go in and rebuild some of the
inner cities and in fact when we were
coming along as an economy and the
record growth we saw in the
african-american community in other
areas it was actually opportunity zones
that were far outpacing that increase by
about 8% you saw a rise in wages and a
rise in in jobs being given in those in
those communities that's also very
important criminal justice reform was a
was a significant piece of legislation
as well something that no previous
president had done but many had talked
about so many in the african-american
community and and those in the minority
communities were you know given
disproportionately high sentences for
various crimes and he wanted to make
sure that injustice was corrected he did
that as well so there are lots of things
this president has done not because of
someone's race because but because it
was right to do any concern at the White
House that this civil unrest and all the
damage that it could slow the pandemic
recovery and are you prepared for a
possible second wave of coronavirus
we're looking into that as well I mean
let's not forget it was the media who
just a week previous was saying how
anyone go out and enjoy themselves a
Memorial Day and social distancing has
to be kept up and you must wear a mask
all that went out the window when people
started you know rioting in the street
no one in the media said that was an
issue at all nobody even cared it was
almost like we're seeing articles now
saying the virus doesn't even you know
it's like it fails to exist once people
start rioting and looting doesn't make
any sense at all we know what social
distancing did to get us to the point
even begin to reopen and we know what
masks did to help protect the American
people we hope people are sensible and
about that we want to reopen but we want
to do it in a rational reasonable
responsible way they were doing that and
I think the majority of Americans are
doing that but in some of these major
cities where we saw spikes before in
coronavirus we hope that the people who
decide to to protest do it peacefully
number one but they do it in a manner
that's that's you know in line with our
guidance and our guidelines that you do
wear a mask you do socially distance
because that's how we begin to slow the
spread we've done it you've seen numbers
going down in these metropolitan areas
and we're hoping they don't go up
because of coronavirus but I imagine the
data will will let us know that one way
the other very shortly one last thing I
know I have to let you go any one of
these things is a crisis the pandemic
the tremendous hit to the economy now
the mass protests dealing with all of it
what's it like at the White House on a
daily basis right now these are historic
times there's no question about that I
imagine many white houses face a crisis
or two during their time but this
administration for whatever reason has
been faced with a lot of a lot of
different types of attacks many of them
have been political in nature as you
know the complete hoax of a Russia
meddling situation in which they accused
the president of colluding with a
foreign power which was proven to be
completely false you saw some of that
testimony with rod Rosenstein saying he
wouldn't have moved forward this had he
known then what he knows now you've seen
the impeachment you've seen Kavanagh
you've seen all the ridiculous things
they've tried to attack this presence
with from a political standpoint and now
we're faced
you know a pandemic as you mentioned you
know it looks like it's gonna be an
active hurricane season as well so it
seems like it never stops but you know
you have the right president for the
right time in that no one moves faster
than he does no one is more up to the
challenge than he is no one has taken
the stronger leadership role than he has
and will continue to do and so all the
things he's done in addition to just the
crises that we faced let's not forget
about the rebuilding the military for
example the massive trade deals we had
to protect the American worker bring
back jobs to this country tax cuts to
put more money in our pockets all the
major steps he's done a criminal justice
reform for example it's be HBCUs we just
talked about as well those things for
heaven's sakes our accomplishment on top
of their relentless political assaults
that he's faced so it's an honor and
privilege to work every single day and
and it's a blessing to work for this man
because I can I can assure you this and
every conversation I have with him
whatever decision he makes it boils down
to one real question for him is does it
improve the lives of the American people
and if it does he's going to do it
Hogan ghibli deputy assistant to the
president and principal deputy press
secretary thank you so much for coming
on the run down thank you so much have a
great day
[Music]
this is jason chaffetz with your foxnews
commentary
coming up it has not been the best of
times even as we reopen more businesses
we still have close to a thousand
Americans a day dying with the
coronavirus tens of millions of
Americans are still out of work
and there's now been ten nights of
protests over George Floyd's death in
Minneapolis there's been looting and
terrible vandalism in some of those
cities the riots themselves had been
horrible I will say I don't think they
were as bad as 1968 when cities were
literally on fire
Chris Wallace is the host of Fox News
Sunday you know you put combined
together the Floyd murder alleged murder
I guess I should say which is as bout as
rotten as horrific to look at as any of
these unfortunate things of we've ever
seen and then the reaction the protests
which I think are solid and you know
that's as old as the the founders in the
Constitution but then the rioting and
the looting which was our of all of them
you know they're they're lawbreakers
they should be put in jail and then put
that in the context of we've been going
through this coronavirus for three
months and 40 million Americans are
unemployed and it's it's facing a tough
time in this country what I thought well
you said a few times on this program
that President Trump will be judged in
November on his response to the corona
virus and the health and the job aspects
there now you add this and the protests
nobody said he caused the virus nobody
said he killed George Floyd but people
are gonna ask has he made things better
or worse than they could have been I
think this was a very tough week for the
President and and you know just think of
who called him out this week you know
with the the regardless I'm saying this
that was a political analyst I'm not
saying this as somebody who's either for
the President or against the president I
I'm just covered the story and and you
you had the Episcopal bishop of
Washington call him out for having the
photo-op in front of st. John's Church
you had the archbishop the top Catholic
official in Washington call him out for
the same thing and and pushing peaceful
protesters away you had James Madison's
secretary just you know ream him on on
violating the Constitution spent three
years dividing the country not not
uniting it Admiral Mullen Mike Mullen
the former
a chairman of the Joint Chiefs the same
thing and even Marquez for his current
Secretary of Defense breaking with him
on using the military and invoking the
in Suresh insurrection act I mean forget
the personalities involved to have some
of the top current and retired military
brass and the two most important
religious leaders in Washington all call
you out that's a bad week for any any
person see a retired Marine general John
Allen who used to be in charge of the
ISIS fight he added his name on to the
list
calling the president out now with the
cob yet again that it's early we always
say that some of these presidential
polls are looking really good for Biden
to see the new Fox polls in Arizona Ohio
Wisconsin I did but you know if you had
to if you had to choose right now
whether you is a political team you were
on would provide nur for Trump you'd
have to say Biden right now is the
favorite I new decide what I really want
to talk about is your new book
so next John do that please Chris let's
not talk about I'm gonna twist your arm
make you talk about your new book comes
out next Tuesday the ninth you were nice
enough to send me a copy
I burned right through it called
countdown 1945 sell some for Father's
Day and just tell people what it's about
first well and then so pleased and
that's what people tell me I mean it's
the the story the 116 days that changed
the world on April 12 1945 Truman finds
out that he is the new president FDR has
died and the Secretary of War Henry
Stimson takes him aside after just after
he's been sworn in and says you don't
know anything about this but we have
been developing a super weapon for the
last three years that is literally the
first that Truman ever heard about the
Manhattan Project to develop the atomic
bomb 116 days later he drops it on
Hiroshima to try to end the war with
Japan the Second World War and this is
the story of those 116 days and it's not
just Truman and how he makes I think
arguably the biggest decision that's
ever been made it's also the scientists
at Los Alamos the flight crew on Tinian
Island that flew the Enola Gay it's a
woman on the home for
named Ruth Sisson who's working at Oak
Ridge Tennessee and she's fiddling with
these dials to try to keep the the meter
in the right spot not to go in the red
she doesn't know what she's doing really
except it needs to keep the the dial
where it is she's in rich in uranium and
then there's also 10 year old Dakota
Mora who's a little girl who's at ground
zero in Hiroshima when the bomb is
dropped and you know like a like a movie
you know it's it's the White House Los
Alamos Oakridge Hiroshima and we toggle
back and forth among all the different
spots and all the different characters
as we get closer and closer to August 6
when they drop the bomb it really does
kind of read like a movie or a you know
miniseries where you you bounce back and
forth between these locations and these
characters I'm glad you brought up Ruth
Ruth Sisson because and they go tomorrow
like it's those little stories we we all
know about Oppenheimer and Truman but
this ruse is and woman she's one of
thousands of people thousands of
Americans who worked on the bombs not
knowing what they were doing until it
was over yeah this is an extraordinary
thing first of all I want to say that
this is really you can feel that what
however you feel about the decision to
drop the bomb and I come down in the end
the Truman really had no choice he had
to drop it but but it's a story of
American triumphant and all these people
pulling together whether it's scientists
or the military or just people on the
homefront and and you know as I said
Sisson she's told that you're doing
something to help in the war but she
doesn't know he's operating something
called a Calot Ron machine and there was
a joke at the time my job is so secret
even I don't know what I'm doing and she
is a perfect example of that and the
reason that her story is so poignant is
her boyfriend later fiance and husband
Lawrence Huddleston is an Army medic in
the worst of the fighting over in Europe
and the war in Europe ends on May 8th
and then the question is are all of
these the the hundreds of thousands of
American soldiers now going to be
shipped over to the Pacific to help in
Bay
Japan and the guesstimate was it was
going to cause at least a half a million
American casualties and the war was
continued this is in May June of 45 the
world was going to continue until
November of 46 to another year and a
half so you know she's looking at this
as life and death
boring Europe is over we won my my love
is safe and now is he going to be
shipped to an even bloodier war in the
Pacific yeah and also Truman it hadn't
really struck me he was sort of a bit of
an accidental president I mean ten years
before this he was a County Judge he
just kind of found himself in the Senate
and then found himself on the ticket
with FDR and then found himself as
president and making one of the most
monumental decisions the president ever
had to make you're absolutely right I
mean Roosevelt didn't even care who his
Vice President was Henry Wallace was the
current vice president remember that's
was third Roosevelt's third term and the
and the party felt that he was too far
to the left and there was frankly
concerned that Roosevelt has been very
worn down by the war it might not
survive a fourth term which he won in
1944 so they thought we've got to get
him off the ticket Henry Wallace and and
then who was it that they were going to
put on the ticket and they come on the
name of this fairly backbench you know
not terribly well known Missouri senator
named Harry Truman who only 2% in the
Gallup poll yes they had polls back then
only 2% of Americans supported for vice
president and the calculation by the
Democratic Party Chiefs was well he'll
hurt the ticket beliefs so it was just
he'll do the least harm let's make him
the vice president and Roosevelt
completely cuts him out he only meets
privately he's the vice president for 82
days and Roosevelt only meets with him
in private twice
so after he's sworn in and then Stimson
tells him about the Manhattan Project
that is the first the Roosevelt I mean
I'm sorry the Truman never even knew
that there was a project to try to
develop an atom bomb he did he didn't
even know what existed so you're right
and that is a phrase that's used about
him the accidental president yeah you
get a cool story about how he found out
that he
president that I guess Nancy Pelosi
shared with you and that's in the book
well that's how that's what I came to
write the book just real quickly I was
in a meeting with a bunch of reporters
with Nancy Pelosi and she says this is
the room where Truman got the call you
got to come to the White House in April
12th and he hangs up the phone and he
says Jesus Christ in General Jackson and
and I've been thinking about writing a
book and trying to find a great moment
and that was the moment when I got when
I came up with the idea
Truman becomes president and I didn't
know how many days it was and 116 days
later he dropped the bomb and there's a
documentary with it that's going to be
on the channel so yeah there's a fox
news documentary on Sunday night
assuming and let's hope for a lot of
more important reasons we don't have any
riots in the streets 10 o'clock Eastern
Time on Sunday and I have to say you
know I I was somewhat involved and but
but it was the documentary unit at Fox
it is a heck of an hour I promise you
you you will like it but it's no
substitute for buying and reading the
book so there you go all right well I
know a father-in-law who's probably
going to get one for Father's Day I was
gonna say perfect Father's Day gift and
and that's frankly one of the reasons
that the the publisher which is an
imprint of Simon & Schuster there are a
lot smarter than me we had they said you
got to put this out in June as a
Father's Day gift and also it's the 75th
anniversary of Kirishima
this dog has sex exactly 75 years to the
day since the bomb was dropped on
Hiroshima soon-to-be best-selling author
Chris Wallace hosted Fox News Sunday
Chris always a pleasure we'll catch you
next week from your lips to God's ear
thank you so much Chris I appreciate it
talk to you next week
it's the Perino and steyr Walt I'll tell
you what podcast Dana Perino of the five
and Fox News political editor Chris
Stein wall dissect the ins and outs of
national politics subscribe and listen
now by going to fox news podcasts
dot-com
Rayden review the fox news rundown on
Apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with Tonya J
powers Jane Collins has survived the
Spanish flu and two world wars and now
she can add something else to that
survival list the corona virus she's a
hundred and four years old and lives in
the UK the Southwest News Service
reports she's back at the care home
where she lives in England
she's now one of the oldest people in
the UK to contract kovat 19 and she
recovered from it in just 10 days
she says she's feeling stronger every
day and credits her love of champagne to
helping her kick the virus her great
niece Sarah Baum forth backs that up
Baum forth is a nurse and says her
family was terrified when Jane was
diagnosed in late April they expected
the worst but Baum forth says her great
aunt has a an iron Constitution and is
fiercely independent even continuing to
drive her car until she was 101 Jane
worked in the health care industry
before she retired and she spent some of
that time working in Royal Derby
hospital the very place where she was
treated for the coronavirus enjoy your
cake in Champagne Jane and here's to
your health
Tonya joy powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentaries
and Chaffins what's on your mind equal
application of the law justice is what
we all need to calm the country quote
the greatness of our nation comes from
our commitment to the rule of law in
quote set Attorney General William bar
and he is correct without justice
everyone in our country is at risk
everyone I spoke with on all sides of
the political spectrum was sickened
disgusted
saddened frightened and mad about the
apparent excessive force by Minneapolis
police officer evidently carrying out
his own justice on George Floyd who was
handcuffed and pinned to the ground for
nearly nine minutes he died it should
have never happened unfortunately there
are a small number of people who seek
chaos in the United States they take
advantage of tragedy and try to compound
it with violence fear and rioting while
there must be swift justice for the
death of George Floyd there can be no
acceptance of lawlessness after four
nights of violence and rioting in this
city Minneapolis Mayor Jacob fry boldly
stated this is no longer about
protesting this is about violence and it
has to stop perceptive
but unfortunately four nights too late
we should not tolerate rogue cops nor
should we tolerate protesters who go too
far by stoking violence and breaking the
law
ultimately the long term solutions for
peace prosperity and United communities
will be found in families neighborhoods
churches safe schools good jobs and a
justice system that is fair they will be
a founding communities where Lady
Justice wears a blindfold and equally
administers the law no matter who you
are where you came from or who you know
until that confidence is restored no
community deserves to be overrun with
looting and fear order must be restored
as the wheels of justice turn bar said
quote we must have law and order on our
streets and
in our communities and it is the
responsibility of the local and state
leadership in the first instance to halt
this violence the Department of Justice
including the FBI marshals ATF and DEA
and all of our 93 US Attorney's across
the country will support these local
efforts and take all action necessary to
enforce federal law
end quote the good news is solutions
will be found in our local communities
where an individual's voice can have the
most impact if we wait for Congress to
solve these issues it most likely will
never happen these problems can be
expeditiously addressed by prioritizing
justice and rejecting fear and violence
i'm jason Chaffetz or remember our
Congress and Fox News contributor
you've been listening to the box news
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com love fox news
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust and
click the Fox news rundown playlist for
the latest episodes